Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Star Wars Rogue one
non-spoilery review make sure you go see the
movie.
It ended up being so much better than I expected
it to be.
There is a Star Wars giveaway happening right
now, it's for two IMAX gift certificates.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so that
you don't miss out on anything.
So right off the bat Mads Mikkelsen is just
so amazing in this movie Felicity Jones did
a great job but I feel like mas Mikkelsen,
no matter what his role is he's always going
to do something interesting, regardless of
how he's written, but Donnie Yen what of bad
ass.
I was so happy when I heard he was going to
be in this movie you always get hype when
you know Donnie Yen is in a movie.
And you know he gets to fight a ton of people
and then Ben Mendelson just what an amazing
antagonist the way they play with the Jon
Williams music the way they open the film
to differentiated from other Star Wars films.
There's so many things that are similar yet
very different about this that made it so
much better than I ever thought it could be
there so many things that we can say about
this film also.
You know total success off the bat doing a
film that does not rely on the skywalkers
at least in a major way or on the idea of
Jedi with light sabers.
It does is amazing job of broadening the mythology
of the force in a really interesting way.
And just proves that you can tell a really
interesting story from start to finish with
a single film you don't need an entire trilogy
to tell an amazing story.
So if this proves anything, it's that they
can totally do just one off films in different
corners the Star Wars galaxy.
They effectively visited more different new
planets that we've never seen before in like
the first 20 to 30 minutes of the movie that
we saw in the entirety of Star Wars episode
seven, so the other big achievement is that
it also enriches the other movies even though
it exists by itself with a different group
of characters is just like the Col. of a story
that we had before we knew the rebels had
stolen the death Star plans they took that
and turned it into a movie and it totally
worked in now when you go see a new hope episode
for after you see this movie.
You'll have so much more context the moments
like Darth Vader at the beginning of episode
four where he's talking to the Imperial Council
about the new death Star being completed will
mean so much more in that's even just like
a little part of it.
We don't even need a sequel to this movie
and I think that's kind of the idea is that
you know they'll take like little pieces of
stories from the previous Star Wars films
and then turn that into something like Rogue
one only just in a vastly different part of
the galaxy during a different time.
In a different context that will enrich the
other saga films without necessarily being
beholden to the Skywalker family.
The other amazing thing about this is that
it also broadens the Empire in the rebellion
as characters themselves like you have the
characters you fall around in the film, but
then you have the idea of the empire, it's
self as this living organism which is a lot
of people working for it.
Just because it's evil doesn't mean that everybody
that works for the Empire all the officers
agree with each other is this big group of
diverse people and you what's the big thing
that we knew about the Empire in the previous
films there bad the rebels are good.
But this film puts the war back in Star Wars
it is a really good job of being stored like
a war documentary mixed with this real down
and dirty Heise movie.
So the rebels even though we know they're
on the right side of this have to do really
bad things to accomplish their goals though
it's much grayer it's not just like really
good guys against really bad guys there or
so credit character is arguably like the big
antagonists of the film, but in no way does
he feel like an Emperor or a Darth Vader type
character somebody who you know is doing really
evil things like it took a long time to figure
out that Darth Vader had something underneath
that mast that was just this terrible really
raspy breathing person that crushed everyone's
throats, when they displeased him see you
get a much more well-rounded character and
in developing the or so credit character you
learn a lot about the power structure of the
Empire.
Not everybody loves everybody else inside
the Empire, especially, just as they're making
giant super weapons, so it's really funny
how they mythologized the death Star and this
too because it's kind of like this white elephant
pie-in-the-sky project that these weirdos
are working on in the rest of the Empire,
just completely does not care about it until
it's finished and we get to episode for with
this counsel scene, with like the other Imperial
Council members and the general just really
excited about it.
Not everybody in the Empire up at the top
shared those feelings when they first got
started, so re-shoots I know a lot of you
are asking about the Riches like what did
they change about the film.
They did a whole bunch of stuff to change
just big portions.
So if you look at the trailers, most of these
scenes did not make it into the final version
of the film, which is kind of weird, but a
lot of times that happens like the market
the film really early on, but then later the
find better ideas the make subtle changes
in scenes that completely change the context,
so they just have to cut out like whole big
swaths of the film as weird as it sounds the
film is great.
So all the stuff that they changed was for
the better.
What happened is they said they initially
shot most of the film in a really handheld
documentary war film type way.
So when they got to the edit.
They realize that there was just like a little
connective tissue missing between scenes and
they turned it into more of what you would
think of is a traditional Star Wars film.
So that being said, if you been asking for
a more mature Star Wars film like a Star Wars
film.
This made not no not so much for like really
little kids but for adults Rogue one is it
just in the way it treats some of the themes
of war in the galaxy in the stuff that it's
dealing with.
So even though all the characters are really
funny, the comedy is great is actually a pretty
serious Star Wars film the you have all these
rebels that are coming together all over the
galaxy like this is still towards the beginning
of the rebellion, it's between episode three
and episode four in the timeline, but you
have this Empire that's trying to steal all
the resources from all these different planets
the people that lived there saying this is
bull crap are going to come together and stop
you from doing this.
And that's where you get to the rebellion.
So the film does a really good job of showing
you that process like how they come to that
conclusion and what it is that makes the Empire.
So terrible.
Even though not everybody that works for the
Empire are terrible people, so what's the
other really big thing about Star Wars films.
All the creatures all the costumes.
They had some of the most diverse group of
aliens in the film that you've ever seen in
Star Wars now like George Lucas always made
a really big deal about trying to make the
newer films like the prequel's.
Even the clone wars look as different as possible
from previous Star Wars films.
But like I said the first 20 to 30 minutes
of the film you visit so many different planets
and as you go to all those different places
everywhere looks very different in terms of
the people the aliens creatures.
The sheer quantity of creature work in this
film is just amazing and the cosplay is going
to be on fire next year at comic con like
the shore troopers look amazing, the deaths
troopers even from the Empire standpoint that
just forget about the rebels for second.
But all the new Empire stuff they show up
so the design language floes a lot from episode
four because this is kind of a prequel to
episode four.
So like all the star destroyers the death
Star itself looks familiar.
But they found little ways to just include
a bunch of new things with in that design
scheme select the shore troopers are new the
death troopers anew, but the interesting thing
is is they said they also change Darth Vader's
costume.
So like even minor details like that or even
when they were on the sets filming the scenes
like in the background you know they have
a lot of playback on the screen like when
you're on a star destroyer Ben Mendelson the
actor said that it totally took him back to
his childhood because he was standing in front
of all the screens you doing his lines and
they were on this playback loop and just looking
at them.
They look like they were straight out of 1977.
They were so perfect they did such a good
job earlier this year.
Marketing the film showing up behind the scenes
stuff like if you're a big geek for the way
they make Star Wars films, then he will go
crazy when you see Rogue one.
So the film does a really good job of like
being in this very Star Wars episode four,
five and six universe just because the design
language in the time period that falls in
without being completely beholden all the
Skywalker stuff and just slavishly setting
up other movies like episode seven does not
that I think that Star Wars episode seven
was a bad movie I just feel like Rogue one
does a much better job of what it set out
to do like a really small self-contained story
about a really big event in the history of
the galaxy while at the same time enriching
the other films Star Wars episode seven had
like the Herculean task of being the first
Star Wars movie in such a long time.
There was no way that it was good to live
up to everyone's expectations.
So with that in mind here's my new ranking
of all the Star Wars movies from favorite
two slightly less favorite.
There are no Star Wars films that I actively
hate.
Even the prequel's.
I don't hate the prequel's.
Some of them.
I just don't like is much as the others, so
favorite film Empire than a new hope return
of the Jedi then Rogue one which I like a
little bit better than episode seven and then
attack of the clones, so let me know what
your favorite Star Wars films from most favorite
to least favorite just rank them all in the
comments.
Just because I feel like Rogue one is good
enough that a lot of people will feel like
it's even better than Star Wars episode seven.
That's the real surprise of the year.
I'm so blown away that they were able to do
that now.
It might not make quite as much money is episode
seven because you have like a lot of people
that normally wouldn't go see a Star Wars
film were so excited at the idea of a new
Star Wars film that last year they just got
up off their asses and went to the movie theater,
whereas like this or the like okay you know,
I saw stores last year.
I don't need to see it again all this I'll
wait for episode eight.
If I want to go back.
So, I still think it's going to make an ungodly
sum of money and it's going to show Lucasfilm
that they can do small one-off films about
other parts of the galaxy other groups of
characters that we haven't met before as long
as it enriches the other films, so next big
elephant in the room.
What does that say about the Obi-Wan Kenobi
film the everyone's been clamoring for.
That means they can still do stuff like that
but they shouldn't be afraid to try brand-new
things which is really where were headed after
episode nine like the idea that we might not
have films about the Skywalker saga anymore
they just move on to something else.
So I will be doing a Star Wars Obi-Wan Kenobi
video really soon and all explained like what's
going on with him in the Star Wars universe.
They do have a plan for him.
There's a reason why they haven't announced
a Star Wars Obi Wan film, because money is
not concerned they would make $1 billion on
Obi Wan film issue that they have a very specific
plan for that character within the scope of
the new saga films, so rest assured Star Wars
episode eight in episode nine have a plan
for the Obi Wan character in I'll explain
what I think that is in my next Star Wars
video.
So what's going to happen is I'll do my spoiler
Easter egg video later this weekend I'll do
the Obi Wan video before that later tonight
I have some new Spider-Man homecoming that
I'm going to post and then I'm going see Rogue
one again, so if you've already seen, try
to go see it twice because there a lot of
Easter eggs some of them are actually pretty
easy to spot in one of them is a planet name
so just that you know there's a planet that
is named, it's an anagram for one of the biggest
Star Wars characters of all time.
So look out for that when you go see the movie.
I am so happy that this ended up being good
while you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to rewatch the Spider-Man homecoming
trailer and you can click here to rewatch
that Rogue one behind the scenes video thank
you so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight!